Kate Hudson makes her red carpet debut  with new boyfriend Danny Fujikawa  [Music]  the 38 year old actress stepped out with  her new man for their first public  appearance as a couple at the LA  premiere of her mom's new film snatched  Wednesday night Kate and her musician  beau were not shy about showing their  affection the to posed for photos with  their arms around one another and even  kissed for the cameras the couple first  sparked dating rumors in March when they  were spotted kissing after a romantic  dinner in NYC but due Kate's parents  approve et spoke with both Goldie Hawn  and Kurt Russell on the red carpet he's  a nice guy Danielle you approve I always  approve Kate brings good guys he's a  great guy yeah it's very special  [Music]  you